welcome back to our course machine
learning for high-throughput biomedical
data in this lecture we will talk about
processing high throughput data
specifically we will take one of the
data sets from the publication we
started to review and prepared for
analysis in order to understand the
samples and where they came from we will
learn about breast cancer classification
and explore The Associated NCBI file
project but before we start it is
important to note that in the context of
machine learning data selection and
preparation are critical for good
analysis in fact many data scientists
and bioinformaticians spend the majority
of their time cleaning understanding and
preparing the data even before they get
started there is even a common saying
garbage in garbage out it means that
whether your model or analysis are good
or bad
if the source data is bad there is
nothing not even the advanced methods
and computational capabilities that will
make your results any good with that in
mind let's review the data we will be
working with in this lecture we will be
using the tion for platform well use it
to process raw data so make sure you
have the credentials you received with
the course if you don't have your
credentials or have trouble signing in
please email me directly the section we
will use is under NGS next generation
sequencing data it is called RNA seek
slash chip parallel analysis of NGS and
microarray data when using the platform
make sure that you take notice of the
informational pop ups that will appear
while building the pipeline these pop
ups provide detailed information on each
step that we take if you would like to
learn about the algorithm you can
usually find a link to a reference
publication in those pop ups so let's
review the data set we are dealing with
the main topic that it pursues is
precision medicine this time we will
talk about breast cancer and some of the
treatments available for this disease as
we saw in the previous lecture
high-throughput data like genomics
transcriptomics and others are becoming
more and more affordable and accessible
while precision medicine relies on such
information to diagnose patients to
understand disease at the molecular
level and even prescribe treatments to
patients relying on such information
let's take
look at what that exactly means as you
remember the publication with selected
deals with breast cancer a mammogram is
an x-ray picture of the breast that
doctors used to look for early signs of
breast cancer in this example you can
see that the tumor is highlighted once
it's found it is critical to establish
whether it's malignant or benign and
what tissue it is originating from once
the tumor is characterized by its
phenotype like size tissue origin etc
additional information can be obtained
by checking for presence of specific
proteins characteristic of cancer if
these proteins are known
immunohistochemistry or antibody
staining can be used to find if they are
expressed or not specific molecular
markers are characteristic of cellular
events such as proliferation or cell
death these are typically referred to as
biomarkers based on these biomarkers we
can know something about the tumor and
in many cases have a pretty good idea
about treatment options but a protein
expression especially measured with
immunohistochemistry provides us with
only a select number of biomarkers that
we can check for what if other processes
are going on that we should take into
consideration oftentimes
immunohistochemistry is used in
combination with gene expression panels
to explore such variation here on the
right you can see the Pam 50 panel it is
a panel of 50 genes that shows their
expression high expression is shown in
green and low and red now you can also
notice that we can see patterns or
profiles of gene expression using
various combinations of genes
researchers started classifying breast
cancer into several subtypes luminal a
normal like luminal B her - enriched and
basal like how can this molecular
subtyping be used because many patients
characterized with such methods were
observed for a long period of time we
can assess the risk levels for
recurrence and survival in this chart
you can see a Meyer Kaplan curve of
survival or recurrence based on to
clinical gene panel Pam 50 and Oncotype
DX these panels separate patients into
three groups
high medium and low risk based on these
assessments a treatment is selected
traditional treatments for cancer are
surgery radiotherapy and chemotherapy
each one of these treatments can have a
harmful side effect and is known to be
effective in very specific situations
for example tumors are typically
irradiated before surgery
or if they're considered to be somewhat
benign chemotherapy target cell
proliferation and often it ends up
affecting many other cells in the body
not just the tumor causing severe
discomfort to patients and in some cases
leading to complications however since
the 1990s a new type of treatment
started emerging in clinical use
targeted cancer therapy one such
treatment is called Herceptin or trust
to Zermatt it is a monoclonal antibody
that blocks the her2 receptor blocking
it from receiving the growth factor
hormone and preventing cell growth but
even though Herceptin is considered a
major breakthrough for patients with
her2 protein overexpression targeted
therapies have not become a silver
bullet cure for cancer in early stage
curable her2 positive breast cancer
trust is a map containing regimens
improved overall survival and
disease-free survival however the
studies also showed an increased risk of
heart disease and resistance developed
by most patients here you can see the
proposed mechanism of action for this
drug as you can see on the picture the
antibody causes a sequence of events
that disrupt the signaling and
proliferation cellular pathway on the
other side we see the disruption that
takes place these changes cause
resistance or lack of response mutations
polymorphisms and lack of expression are
all factors contributing to this
resistance the study of how Herceptin
works in its molecular mechanism of
action continues providing new insight
into combinations of factors that could
lead to a significant number of
decisions that should be taken when
prescribing the drug from observed
changes in receptor gene variation erbb2
encodes for the her2 receptor changes to
other players in this
pathways and other variation caused by
the treatment response this is a great
example of how the complexity of sub
cellular mechanisms lead to both
breakthrough therapies and new
challenges where each new challenge is
characterized by many players and
interactions between them
the study of these changes will be the
focus of this project where we'll take
the gene expression data and apply
machine learning to help us extract
meaningful insight into the nature of
pres cancer itself the publication we
are taking data from has over 50
different breast cancer subtypes so
approximately 10,000 genes are expressed
for each cell line that has an
associated clinical subtype the same
cell line were also treated with 70
different approved in experimental
compounds in IG 50 or inhibition of
growth profile for each cell line was
measured the first thing that we would
want to do is find this project on NCBI
so let's go ahead and do that on NCBI
data is organized in bio projects that
contain links to publications various
metadata about samples and if fraud data
is available it can be downloaded here's
how you find the data set and download
information about the samples let's take
a look at the download a table and see
what's inside
data is stored in a compressed format or
SRA sequence read archive the SRA
archive contains runs or samples they
start with the letters s RR or a
sequence read run if you download and
extract the SRA archives you will find
that they contain fast q files inside
with extensions underscore 1 and
underscore 2 at the end looking at the
metadata given with this project we can
see that the data was produced using
pair and sequencing it is a technique
that uses simultaneous reading of each
fragment from both ends thus improving
the quality of sequencing in addition to
the file name in its download location
the metadata shows cell line names used
in each run and the clinical subtype
associated with that sample to save us
some time
we already downloaded and on
the archive preparing it for us to use
on the platform so for our first
pipeline we will select some normal like
and cloud and low samples to do the
analysis we have five normal like and
six cloud and low samples you can do
your own search on the internet and read
more about these cell lines the cells
even look differently as you can see in
the picture what we also know about the
clinical classification is that cloud
and low is a much more aggressive cancer
that is often grouped under triple
negative breast cancer triple negative
means the tissue tests negative for
three main receptors ER or estrogen
receptor PR progesterone receptor and
her2/neu anapa dermal growth factor
receptor 2 I think that we now know what
kind of data we will be dealing with as
I said in the beginning we have to
carefully prepare the data for any
machine learning in the next session we
will take the uploaded files on the T
bio info server and run an RNA seek
pipeline to generate a table of
expression